thank you amcham for this opportunity to
speak
to both sides of the atlantic at once
it's time for the atlantic to become
once again
the beating heart of global cooperation
people on both sides of the ocean are
confronted today
with a breathtaking set of challenges
the pandemic
the economic recovery the fight against
climate change
but if europe and america join forces
none of these challenges are too big
and today after four difficult years
brussels and washington finally speak
the same language again
it is the language of cooperation in
international affairs
the language of free enterprise and fair
competition
the language of science-based
policy-making
it's the language of our common
democratic values
upon which the transatlantic community
has thrived
for over 70 years now
i am a convinced atlanticist
and even when we disagreed with the
previous u.s administration
i never stopped believing that europe
and america
belong together we are one transatlantic
community
i know this is also what you stand for
at the american chamber of commerce to
the european union
you kept alive the flame of
transatlantic cooperation
through the years and until this new
chapter in the history of our friendship
with the us
you have been on the right side of
history
and i would like to thank you for that
your annual transatlantic conference
comes at a momentous time
for our partnership with the us it's
been a month of intense contacts
between the european commission and the
biden administration
in late february at the g7 we took a
first step
towards a renewed transatlantic
corporation
president biden announced a two billion
dollar contribution in 2021
for covax and this is such an important
step
covax is the global facility to buy
vaccines
for low and middle-income countries
europe contributed to its inception and
creation last year
and we financed it with 2.2 billion
euros from team europe
now it's great that the us is
joining forces with us again together we
can
help reach the goal of vaccinating
two billion people in developing
countries by the end of this year
and we need to bring more donors on
board and we can only
make it if europe and america
play as one team on
vaccine solidarity and vaccine openness
europe is walking the talk the european
union has exported over 45 million doses
of vaccines
since the beginning of february and
these vaccines went to 33 different
countries
on top of this european vaccines
went to low and middle-income countries
through covax
plenty of components that are necessary
to produce vaccines have traveled
between the two sides of the atlantic in
both directions
and this kind of openness is also
crucial
to deliver vaccines all around the world
so i hope that other countries will also
open up
in a spirit of reciprocity and in our
mutual interest
cooperation to overcome the pandemic
will be an important part of the new
transatlantic agenda
but there's much more earlier this month
i had a very positive discussion with
president biden about our new agenda for
cooperation
and as a symbol of this fresh start
president biden and i agreed
to suspend all our tariffs in the
context of the airbus
boeing disputes for an initial period
of four months it's a first step
but it speaks volumes about the goodwill
on both sides of the atlantic
and i believe it sends a very reassuring
message
to all businesses trading between europe
and america
president biden and i also discussed
about putting
a strong green dimension in the recovery
and this was also at the core of john
kerry's visit
to brussels the united states has now
rejoined the paris agreement
so my offer to our american friends is
let's go
even further together let us agree
on the shared transatlantic commitment
to become climate neutral by 2050
a transatlantic road map to climate
neutrality
let us discuss how to put a price
on carbon on both sides of the atlantic
if we do this together we can set a new
climate protection standard for the
whole world
and let us discuss how to reduce the
green premium
of market deployment of new technologies
the european green deal is our new
growth strategy
and i know that the us is our ally also
in this
if europe and the us lead by example
i am sure that many others will follow
the same is true in the digital world
let us create a new
transatlantic rulebook for the digital
economy
a rule book for data protection and
privacy
as well as for the security of critical
infrastructure
a rule book based on our common values
and if we succeed we could set the bar
for the rest of the world these are just
a few headlines from our proposal
of a new transatlantic agenda we are
ready
to write a new chapter in the book of
our oldest partnership at the g7
president biden told us america is back
that's great news for the world
and europe is welcoming america back
so let me wish you all a great
transatlantic conference and thank you
for your attention
you